know because i watched a movie recently
that was about like world war
ii also really [ __ ] awkward being the
only white guy in like a world war two
movie about like the japanese being like
destroyed i was just sitting there in
like my seat like this like
i'm not american just waving the flags
yeah because like like you know like
when the the [ __ ] like
there was like the planes were being
bombed and [ __ ] and i'm like do i like
feel
happy that the japanese got like here
like
are they happy or are they like don
those americans yeah
they got us it was weird
i didn't know like what the vibe is in
the cinema
considering have we talked about that
time we watched
uh what's that film um fukushima
oh fukushima 50. so that we we
holy [ __ ] joey wasn't there i wasn't
saying that
but okay so is it called fukushima 15.
so
there was this film that was made in
japan about the whole fukushima tragedy
and it's my kind of cowardly so we got
invited to like a private screening of
it so we got we got an early commentator
to give our thoughts to them and um you
know
the whole film you know it's it's it's
not he's in it
he's [ __ ] amazing great yeah let's go
ahead yeah there's there's
you know i'd rated the good like six out
of ten there were some really good
moments and then there were some
really boring moments and then there
were these moments in it
where they focused on these american
characters
and the like the american the american
military who
okay who wanted to you know he wanted to
help japan
and for one some of them weren't even
american they were like they're like
south
uh south africa yeah there's one south
mexican dude in it
they were like south african in this
military american military boardroom
and he sounded they didn't even try to
[ __ ] hide it he sounded like such a
thick
and it's not it's not like a light
accident in south africa yeah it's
really [ __ ]
full-on like half of them and i was just
so confusing and yeah
go on yeah and i i can't i can't
remember the exact line but there was
this one do you remember this like
okay do you want to explain the exactly
paraphrasing but it was roughly
something like
so that okay to explain to explain the
scene before he says the line
so it was so obviously the fukushima
emergency was happening
and the americans were like discussing
how to help
help the japanese and how to provide aid
and stuff like that all these scenes
were shot like
so the japanese scenes were shot like
perfect like this cinematography was on
point
and then it cut to like like a [ __ ]
sitcom quality looking
camera when it cut it it
imagine a script right of how japanese
people think that american people talk
about the wall
yeah that's the only way i can describe
how the americans spoke because it was
like
the one line was like when it like the
it blew up
it cut to the americans they were like
man you think they would have learned
how to handle nuclear technology after
we nuked them
and i was like that was like the line
and we all looked at each other like
yeah did you just say that what the [ __ ]
yeah like it's like we were we were in
like this this this like private
screening we looked around it was it was
me
connor sydney and maylin and then every
like just japanese business
the japanese businessmen were like fully
immersed they were quiet and they were
like yes this is
this is how americans speak and i was
looking around at connor city
and we were just all like my jaw was
like we're just here
is this okay i'm like what they can't
say that
can they and then you like it was just
so bad
it was so bad all of it was so bad and
then
i just like to imagine the [ __ ] south
african guy cunning and being like oh i
agree with everyone in this room right
now
who
it was like please don't cut to the
americans please don't cut them out and
it cuts to the [ __ ] americans
it was just like an 80 sitcom you're
totally [ __ ] right and they had like
this flashback scene as well
with this one character this one
american general who had no play in the
plot or whatever
had zero screen time and then they just
it just randomly cuts to a flashback of
him in japan
yeah i'm like why is this in the film
and then like towards the end there's
just a shot of like the americans coming
and giving water bottles to them and
it's like
all right sick i'll i'll i'll
i'll take a bottle of avion just for
nuked but thanks for the water bro
like if that line was in an american
film oh my
god the [ __ ] [ __ ] storm it would stop
that's the thing right it's okay because
it's written
like i assume it was written by a
japanese and outsourced to like an
american company
on a budget i'm [ __ ] guessing because
like there's always guaranteed
the american like outsourcing was like
we have to translate this
can we are we laughing this is right
right
yeah i mean it was fine i guess i just
try not to go to films where japanese
the bad guys i've
kind of learned my lesson yeah yeah it's
uh it's brutal yeah i thought i was
gonna watch tennant but it turned out it
was just a war movie i genuinely
got the wrong tickets yeah the wrong
thing
i paid for the wrong tickets yeah i
wanted to watch tennis i did watch
tennis really good by the way yeah uh
watch it yeah it's basically i want to
watch that as well it's like inception
but
more mind [ __ ] i think really yeah